so let's talk more about becoming
unplugged right that's the that's the
title of your book The unplugged Alpha
the no [__] guide to winning with
women in life you have a few here kind
of key points that you talk about in the
book and I think it's you talk about
these four pillars for a man I don't
know if this is to be to to win with
women but you talk about looks money
status and game can you kind of break
these four pillars down um and unpack
each one of them a little bit Yeah so
those four pillars are actually expanded
in the second edition so you have the
first edition of the book that I
released a few years ago I just released
a second edition which which actually
has seven spokes to this wheel now uh
they are red pill awareness looks money
status game frame and captivation so as
an example like the stuff that you know
you talked about in the book um it it
came to my realization because I do a
lot of coaching with high net worth guys
that are like um they mostly
entrepreneurs licensed professionals I
deal with some athletes some politicians
and stuff like that but guys that are
making a lot of money and I noticed you
know a lot of these guys really struggle
with women so to the notion of
captivation you can't bore a woman you
can do anything you want to a woman but
you can't bore her and I've seen guys
that have extraordinary success in their
life they're weapons in their business
World they run the most you know
successful business they make lots of
money but when it comes to entertaining
women or trying to get a woman into
their frame if they're boring if they're
not captivating they're not going to
keep her around like I had this guy once
and uh he was uh he was like you know
it's just not working out I'm getting
one or two dates and they're not showing
up and this guy's like six foot tall
he's goodlook he's you know he's got a
very successful business like he doesn't
really have any red flags in his life
but he doesn't know how to entertain
women right and I'm like well what are
your hobbies and he's like you know the
thing that I really love now is
overlanding so he's explaining
overlanding to me is you know he's got
this expensive uh Land Cruiser with like
a roof tent and ladders and pop out
stuff and campers and he drives it
Overland and all this sort of stuff and
I said to him I go do you do any of this
overlanding on your dates and he's like
no I just like you know sitting down and
having a drink or I'll just listen to
her talk or whatever and it's like on
your next date do me a favor book an
Overland date tell her a pack a picnic
right so you leave her with some
instructions bring something you know
for the day and you know go and do an
overlanding adventure through the desert
and show her a nice sunset on a nice
Cliff like you can find a place like
that right he goes oh yeah I got lots of
places like that I go with my buddies
all the time I'm like good invite her
into that adventure and you let me know
how that happens right and that blew up
for him you know he had a great time the
date went over several hours you know so
there's a lot of components to to doing
well in life as a man beyond just like
looks money and Status sort of stuff
like I said you got got to be unplugged
you know you got to have good game you
know with women you have to have strong
frame over the longterm basis and you
certainly can't be boring which is why I
say you have to be captivated yeah wow I
love that so much man and I would think
a lot of you know a lot of the guys that
that come to me you know they got the
money in check they're succeeding in
business they're running companies uh
you know they've excelled up the
corporate ladder they're they're so
their money is on point they're doing
good looks status wise it's like you
know the money can obviously lead to get
you the status I would say the men that
I'm struggling or the men that I work
with like the the the lack of the
captivation in their life is because
they found these other outlets
pornography video games Sports and that
becomes their default mode of
entertainment or sedation for themselves
so once we can kind of kick that and our
process of doing that would be what are
things that interest you let's let's
re-engage in some Hobbies let's
re-engage them some in Creative
Endeavors I never thought about helping
these guys create a captivating life but
I love the phraseology there with what
you're doing that's a really big mistake
because because guys see because guys
have been told be a nice guy be a
shoulder to cry on you know be all
interested in her stuff and you know the
truth of the matter is and I hate to say
this but women don't generally lead that
interesting of a life compared to what a
guy does right you know women like to
talk about people men like to do things
and like I said earlier you can do
anything to a woman but bore her so it's
it's unlikely that if you're a guy that
you know for example has an overlanding
truck and likes to do that kind of stuff
and goes off into the desert and watches
a sunset on a cliff like there's very
few people out there that can offer that
experience to a woman so you want to
invite her into your life you don't want
to go into her life especially if you're
older and she's younger like usually I'm
dealing with older more successful guys
that are more interested in dating Youth
and Beauty so it's like you don't want
to go and show up and be like well tell
me more about the Taylor Swift concert
you know that you went to and what did
you wear and you know what outfit was
that sort of thing like that's not going
to get their interest but you know
nodding your head and being like yeah
that was a great concert hop in the
truck and pack a picnic let's go over
here and watch the sunet or check out
the night sky when the Sun goes down
it's a beautiful canvas now you're
talking not many people can offer her
that kind of Adventure right absolutely
man would you say getting unplugged this
is this is a realization I've had over
the last four years of my life you know
um realizing that men women want to be
led you've talked about it multiple
times here like pack a picnic get in the
truck we're going here I was just
literally down south in in Miami with my
family over the weekend and on the way
down there my dad is on a call he's
talking to my aunt she's we're figuring
out where are we going to have dinner
this night and my dad's like where are
we going what did you and my my aunt
literally says I was was waiting on you
to tell me where we're going and I
looked at my dad and I said she's asking
you to lead her tell her where we're
going here's the restaurant 6:30 we're
going to show up it's not even a dating
Dynamic this was literally brother and
sister but she was submitting saying
you're the man tell me where I need to
be tell me what time is this a problem
that you see with guys and is that a
part of being unplugged is realizing
that this is what they're actually
looking for absolutely man women
absolutely crave being led in a
relationship in a date so I'm in a
long-term relationship right now I don't
but when I did I can't count how many
times I heard from women you know how
refreshing it is to have a guy set the
date set the time pick me up take me to
a place and drop me off and I would go
beyond that like I would even tell them
what to wear like if I pick them up on a
dating app for example and I saw in
picture number four they were wearing
like a nice black dress or something I'd
be like I'm picking you up at eight
we're going here wear the nice black
dress from picture four right like when
you lead a woman like that and she can
see you as a giant cuz that's what they
want to be with like women want to be
with a giant GI they don't want to be
with somebody that's going to be like
well I don't know where do you want to
go to eat what time are you free to go
like you have to set it like you have to
you know they they want to be led
despite all of this uh nonsense you hear
out there with toxic feminism how men
and women are equal and they're always
the same you go and see these interviews
all the time online where they have a
table like on these dating podcasts and
there's some girl and she's like yes I'm
a feminist I'm a devout you know to this
mindset and ideology and the host will
be like cool so when you're on a date so
who pays and she's like well the guy
does right okay well you can have
chivalry or you can have equality but
hun you can't have both right so pick
one so the truth of the matter is is
women do want chivalry and if you're GNA
give them chivalry then you have to be
the one that leads in that type of
situation yeah I don't know if you saw
the recent I think it was a viral Tik
Tok that went on it hit a few of the
bigger channels out there and it was a a
left a liberal woman she's talking to
her phone she's in the car and she's
just bitching about why are there no
good liberal men like I want a guy
that's going to set the I made a
reaction video to that one actually did
you really yeah did it's just like mind
blowing right yeah yeah they don't exist
exactly exactly you're seeking a
conservative real masculine man yeah you
want a conservative with a man bun that
sorry that does not exist I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the fulllength podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out